>> Greg: LAST NIGHT WAS THE
PEOPLE'S STATE OF THE UNION.
THE LEFT-WING ANSWER TO
TONIGHT'S STATE OF THE UNION.
DO YOU WANT A TASTE?
HAVE A BUCKET.
>> THIS MAN WHO CLAIMS TO BE
TEDDY GOT RID OF CLIMATE SCIENCE
PROGRAMS ALREADY.
HE ACTUALLY RIDES HIS HORSE TO
WORK LIKE A [BLEEP].
>> Greg: THAT IS FISHER
STEVENS.
I THOUGHT HE WAS DEAD BUT HE IS
STILL ALIVE.
AND APPARENTLY A CELEBRITY.
AFTERWARDS, NEWS OUTLETS FOCUSED
ON ONE THING ONLY: STAR POWER.
NOT THE PRINCIPLES.
STAR POWER.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT, THE EVENT
WAS JUST A REHASH OF ANTI-WAS
HARD LEFT DIATRIBES.
AMERICAN-CAUSED GENOCIDE?
CHECK.
THE RADICALISM BUT THAT IT WAS
STAR-STUDDED.
TRUE, THERE WAS MARK RUFFALO.
IF THAT IS STAR-STUDDED SO IS
ANY REST STOP ON SUNSET
BOULEVARD.
I SHOULD KNOW.
WITH THE PRESS IGNORED, THE SAME
DIVISIVE POLITICS THAT SPOOKS
MOST AMERICANS, BLAMING OTHERS
WHAT'S ALSO WEIRD, THIS EVENT
THE ONLY ONE HERE THEMSELVES.
THE CURSE OF REFUSING TO HEAR
THOSE YOU DISAGREE WITH, YOU
REMOVE THE ONE STEP THAT UNITES
PEOPLE, WHICH IS CONVERSATION.
ONLY LEADS TO CONFLICT WITHOUT
IT, BUT MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT.
THE PEOPLE'S STATE OF THE UNION
MAY NOT BE ABOUT PEOPLE AT ALL
COVER FOR THEIR UNPOPULAR
RADICAL BELIEFS.
THEY NEED THE COVER BECAUSE NO
ONE WANTS LEFTISM.
IT HURTS TOO MANY LIVES.
GREAT MOVIE FOR THE MEDIA BUT
IT'S ONE WILL BE THAT AMERICA
WILL HAPPILY SKIP.
YOU KNOW, JESSE, WHAT DROVE ME
NUTS ABOUT THIS, AND I SAY
DRIVING ME NUTS LOOSELY BECAUSE
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
I AM NUTS ALREADY.
EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT HOW
STAR-STUDDED IT WAS.
THEY LEFT OUT THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT WAS SO PURELY
ANTI-AMERICAN DRIVEL THAT YOU'VE
HEARD FOR 40, 50 YEARS.
A GOSSIP COLUMNIST FOR PEOPLE,
THEY CAN'T HANDLE IT.
>> Jesse: HERE'S HOW I KNEW IT
BE AT THE EVENT AND WE SAID MARK
RUFFALO AND HE SAID WHO IS THAT.
HE SAID WHAT MOVIES I SEE BENIN,
THESE GUYS AREN'T A-LISTERS.
IF YOU PUT THEM ON A PANEL LIKE
THIS, THEY CAN'T DEBATE THE
ISSUES.
IT IS ALL ANGER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF BEING LAZY.
RUFFALO WAKES UP AND DOES
10:00 A.M. YOGA ON THE BEACH IN
THIS GUY IS NOT A HARD WORKER.
BEING AN ACTOR IN HOLLYWOOD IS
THE EASIEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
>> Jesse: I HAVE NO IDEA BUT
HE DOES THAT.
>> Kimberly: I THINK HE MEANS
USED THE PHRASE CLEANSE WHEN HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT WHITE MALES,
LIKE WE NEED TO CLEANSE WHITE
MALE PRIVILEGE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO GO
OVER WELL WITH MIDDLE AMERICA?
LET'S CLEANSE AMERICA OF WHITE
MALE PRIVILEGE.
WHICH BASICALLY SAYS GET RID OF
WHITE MALES.
>> Juan: IT IS ABOUT
PRIVILEGE.
WE TALK ABOUT LOW WATTAGE
A LEFT-WING VERSION OF THE TEA
ACTUALLY AMERICANS.
EVERYDAY AMERICANS.
TELL ME, CELEBRITY.
AMERICANS.
>> Juan: THIS IS NOT REAL?
HOW DID CELEBRITY WORK OUT FOR
HILLARY?
>> Juan: THAN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WATCHING,
STREAMING.
INCLUDING GREG.
>> Kimberly: ON GREG'S BEHALF,
HE SORT OF HAD TO.
>> Juan: LET ME DROP THE BOMB
FOR YOU GUYS.
THE BLAST WAS THERE.
GO AHEAD, BLOW UP.
I KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE
DE BLASIO.
>> Dana: IT'S NOT SURPRISING
HE WAS THERE.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, DO YOU CARE
THAT de BLASIO WAS THERE?
>> Kimberly: IF BIG BIRD WAS
THERE.
I DON'T CARE -- I WOULD HAVE THE
REAL PEOPLE LIKE YOU HAD IN THE
TEA PARTY MOVEMENT IN
CELEBRITIES WITHOUT SCRIPTS.
NOT A GOOD IDEA.
TRYING TO COME FORWARD TO
PROFFER SOME ENTHUSIASM AND A
SENSE OF HONOR AND INTEGRITY TO
I DON'T THINK IT WORKED.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR ME.
I COULD SEE HIM POSSIBLY
RUNNING.
HE'S NOT REALLY A BIG STAR.
>> Kimberly: HE IS VERY INTO
THE ENVIRONMENTS.
>> Greg: HE WAS TALKING BUT
THE PIPELINE PROTESTS.
HOW DID THAT END UP?
>> Dana: GETTING APPROVED.
>> Greg: THANK YOU, MARK.
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
A REAL PICKLE.
THEY HAVE THIS DIVISION.
HOW DO YOU FIGURE IT OUT, YOUR
CHUCK SCHUMER AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT, THE GOAL IN
2018 IS TO TRY TO TAKE BACK THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE.
BUT THE SENATE IN PARTICULAR.
HE'S GOT RED STATE DEMOCRATS
HAVING TO RUN FOR REELECTION IN
TEN STATES WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WON SOME OF THOSE STATES BY
DOUBLE DIGITS.
YET HE HAS A BASE THAT'S PULLING
THEM SO FAR TO THE LEFT, AND
>> Greg: THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT
COMMUNISM AND SOCIALISM AND HOW
MANY MILLIONS OF DIED.
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO
CHALLENGE THEM TO A DEBATE?
CELEBRITIES VERSUS "THE FIVE."
FAVORITE, CYNTHIA NIXON.
SHE MADE A GREAT POINT WHICH IS
A YEAR AGO WHEN TRUMP GAVE A
SPEECH, GUESS WHAT, RUSSIAN WAS
HANGING OVER TRUMP'S HEAD AND
TONIGHT'S SEAT GIVES THIS
SPEECH, RUSSIA IS STILL HANGING
OVER TRUMP'S HEAD.
>> Greg: NONE OF THOSE
LIBERALS IN THE 70s OR 60s,
RUSSIA WASN'T NEVER HANGING OVER
THE COMMUNIST.
>> Dana: DIDN'T CYNTHIA NIXON
SAY SHE MIGHT RUN?
>> Greg: SHE BETTER NOT RUN
UNTIL SHE DOES THE "SEX AND THE
CITY" SEQUEL.